la question elle est simple oubli tout
de suite alors c'est très simple est-ce
que miss france est ce qu'il ya des
magouilles dont miss france ou pas
est-ce que vous pensez que tout est déjà
joué ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
tricher dans miss france depuis quelques
jours l'élection miss france donc fait
beaucoup parler d'elle d'une grosse
polémique
est-ce que tandis que l'émission d'une
miss fait polémique
une autre a été destitué sans vraie
raison valable on a des infos exclusives
on fera un point sur les problèmes qui
lie avec le règlement miss france il ya
un truc entre non mais vous avez un
drôle de bruit alors vous va en parler
alors les chiffres et donc on va faire
un point sur les problèmes qui lie avec
le règlement miss france on aura le
témoignage dont une femme brisée par son
aventure miss france regardez petit
récapitulatif et je vous le disais la
vérité
delphine wespiser books avait été miss
france deux cas l'année 2012 2012 bat
vous seriez aussi cette année sous la
mer à est magnifique c'est parti ça y
est on connaît les noms et les visages
des candidats qui vont représenter leur
région lors de la prochaine élection
miss france sur tf1
et cette année la sélection ne semble
pas du goût de tout le monde sur
internet les messages contre les miss
abondent
certains se plaignent du manque de
représentativité d'autres noms marque
miss nord pas de calais soit toujours là
favorite
et comme chaque année certains
n'hésitent pas à critiquer le physique
des candidates et cette année c'est
encore la mise des hauts de france qui
fait parler d'elle et pour cause il
s'agit d'annabelle varane la soeur du
champion du monde de football raphaël
varane
une nomination qui a du mal à passer
d'autant plus que sa concurrente
principale a été exclue du concours
quelques jours avant l'élection
alors comprenez vous ces polémiques
alors comprenez vous ces polémiques et
c'est vrai que vraiment c'est ouf parce
que tout le monde en a parlé
voilà je vous le dis c'était le 3
octobre dernier on a appris qu'ils
allaient voilà que le casting était
dévoilée et on a appris qu'ils allaient
représenter le nord pas de calais et
c'est annabelle varane c'est la soeur de
raphaël varane alors lui le pauvre n'a
rien à voir là dedans elle aussi elle
est très jolie
la pauvre elle a rien fait je pense pas
qu'elle ait fait la pression mais est ce
que vous comprenez cette polémique est
ce que vous pensez qu'il y à des
personnes favorisées au sein miss france
on va rappeler que dit le règlement le
règlement il faut être né de sexe
féminin
c'est normal
l'avoir de tatouage visible voilà ne pas
avoir subi de transformations majeures
de ses caractéristiques physiques sur la
base desquels a été élu dans le cadre de
son élection régionale être célibataire
non mariés non divorcés n'ont pas que
c'est sans enfant ne pas avoir participé
à des concours un échelon national
voilà et il ya ne pas avoir participé à
des séances photos captation susceptible
de permettre une exploitation auprès du
public d'image dans lesquelles la
candidate apparaît totalement ou
partiellement dénudé voilà l'auteur
d'une grosse bouquin stadistes vous
pouvez rayer jamais être miss france
c'est vrai donc mais alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya une grosse polémique voilà sur
miss france
gilles verdez lorsque vous avez des
infos avant ce que je vais dire je
n'accable pas du tout la soeur de
raphaël varane
vous l'avez dit faut le répéter n'y est
pour rien mais il ya d'immenses
magouilles dans miss france et c'est on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça
les magouilles elles sont dues au comité
le poids des comités est trop important
c'est à dire que vous avez un règlement
à la carte ya des comités où les jeunes
femmes candidates peuvent faire
n'importe quoi elles ne sont pas
sanctionnés il ya des comités ou dès
qu'elles font une petite photo ou
participent à une petite compétition
bout on leur tape dessus qu'elles ont un
tatouage on les élimine
alors que c'est dégueulasse justement
alors on va revenir là dessus la règle
qui fait le plus de ravages dans
l'histoire des élections ce qui est des
différentes polémiques
vous pouvez mettre d'ailleurs le
sommaire un derrière aouicha voilà dans
l'histoire des expos miss france sur
c'est surtout bien sûr les photos les
photos vous n'avez jamais fait de photos
vous non alors gars laetitia bléger par
exemple miss france 2004 qu'a créé le
scandale au sein du comité miss france
pour des photos d'elle nue dans playboy
regardez elle avait été sanctionnée
pages est une merde mais la région s'il
vous plaît alors on y va
merci voilà on l'a vu c'est pas les
photos qui ont fait polémique
s'il vous plaît elle avait ensuite été
sanctionnée par le comité miss france
valérie bègue également avec un énorme
scandale
voilà bah oui bah ouais mais non mais
mais mais mettez les photos qui ont fait
scandale
allah et au calme et vous voilà on la
retrouvera dans le meilleur pâtissier
voilà y'a eu génie journée dans
l'élection 2016 regard des génies voilà
ce génie quoi après mais non mais c'est
pas ça là les photos on a les photos
choquantes
c'est choquant ce genre d'accord et à
dénuder et s'il vous plaît donc voilà
j'ai eu plein de photos comme ça et
surtout est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
des magouilles dans miss france vous
alors vous êtes donc vous êtes océane
lost on est très heureux de vous et vous
avez fait partie de l'élection miss
aquitaine
vous vous êtes fait trahir par le comité
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors en fait
pendant mon élection il y avait des miss
qui avaient droit donc à des places à
l'avant ce donc des bus qui était
réservée pour elle
25 miss sur les quatorze mois j'ai
appelé à la première heure en fait à 10
heures du matin et il se trouve que
j'avais plus de place donc pour ma
famille en plus de sa femme amant et mes
grands parents avaient pris donc des
bida des billets d'avion par don pour
venir me voir exprès et j'avais plus de
place alors que d'autres avaient déjà
180 places prévues à l'avancé
oui mais oui mais ça ça fait pas partie
vraiment lu ces fabricants fait d'accord
nous on n'a pas les jacuzzis une dose
unique était candidate geass paris xiv
était donc j'ai vu ce qui se passait ça
en fait c'est les 5 qui ont le plus de
votes en fait qui ont après qu'ils ont
la chance de passer dans les miss
parce que le jury en fait si on n'a pas
si on n'est pas dans les cinq qui ont eu
le plus de votes par le public
on passe complètement à la trappe ah oui
on ne regarde même pas un précieux en
fait qu'ils choisissent qui est la miss
qui est la première de fiches dans l'es5
notamment donc moi ce qui fait qu'en
fait à la fin j'avais quand même eu
droit à six places parce que deux miss
ont été sympas avec moi et donc ont
vendu des places qu'elles avaient entre
au nom du messie place 181 je veux dire
j'avais alors bien sûr ça parce qu'en
fait le public qui vote est ce que vous
dites est forcément il faut amener donc
des gens avec nous car oui pour pour
tous puissent voter si plus on a dû en a
vécu quemada compagnon plus forcément
ses preuves alors oui visiblement ils
n'ont pas aimé quelques photos que tu as
prise aussi et a été un petit peu
blacklisté je crois que c'est ça aussi
regarder on va voir les photos tu avais
pris les photos en bikini
oui oui voilà voilà voilà
[Rires]
tu as décidé de te rebeller et de poster
cette photo voilà on passe à la c'est
bon voilà c'est bon et donc voilà et
donc tu as posté cette photo
voilà merci et ils ont choisi voilà deux
voilà deux semaines et il est sorti
après que le destituer voilà mais c'est
ce que je voulais après un j'avais plus
envie d'être en rapport en fait avec
voilà avec ces organisations en fait
donc comme je savais très bien que
c'était interdit d'avoir les sharp avec
un verre d'alcool ou une cigarette
tu as trop la patate wajeha aucune
ouverture d'esprit c'est fermé en fait
c'est tellement fort mais c'est ça alors
qu'il savait que c'est le règlement
alors les chéris juste d'être invest
viseur est ce qu'il y a à ce que ces
miss france ou est ce que c'est miss
triche du coup la vérité alors juste je
vais reprendre sur ton élections
régionales moi aussi pour miss alsace
j'avais dit place les autres nanas elle
venait des bus entiers j'ai quand même
gagné parce qu'au final les gens qui
viennent même pour d'autres personnes
c'est à bulletin cacher donc ils peuvent
voter pour quelqu'un d'autre mes parents
étaient là et à côté les gens ont dit ah
mais moi je suis venu pour voilà mais je
vais voter pour la fille avec les
cheveux rouges ils savaient pas que
c'était mes parents donc voilà et au
final j'ai gagné ce que je voulais dire
c'est que tu as signé un règlement donc
tu sais très bien que tu n'as pas le
droit de fumer avec taton et chats je
veux dire à ce moment là dedans mais
reste à l'achat
ça ne devait pas être kadhafi et chupa
ils tablent tous les âges tout ça on le
sait encore heureux que les jeunes
filles ne posent pas tout nu parce que
généralement ces 18 24 ans et parle pas
de ça et j'avais le choix c'est du
fantasme c'est clairement juste d'être
en tête on n'y a pas de triche à miss
alsace à miss france
oui parce que dans ce cas me sens super
on est miss france et miss france à des
délégués dans toutes les régions
voilà qui permet de chapeauter les
filles il ya des élections il ya des
élections départementales ça écrème ça
écrème et ensuite ses fils à qui gagne
les élections départementales peuvent
aller en régionale notamment dans le
nord-pas-de-calais ya énormément de oui
mais si vous avez déjà vu des trucs
bizarres ou pas non pas du tout gilles
verdez alors il ya une polémique qui va
monter après ce que je vais vous révéler
il ya une immense tricherie à miss
france et à delphine vous n'avez pas
pouvoir me démentir vous savez quand ya
le concours mais les 38 ski sont là et
puis on passe à 12
miss d'accord moment pas ce point 12
miss delphine oui c'est le jury qui est
choisie c'est le jury qui est choisie
mais pour alarmant est ce qu'ils
jouaient les bassa c'est une immense
masse karkwa voilà mais c'est selon le
roi ses sauts on ne donne pas les
critères on n'établit pas les votes les
gens les secrets cerveau discrétionnaire
du jury et c'est selon le poids du
comité j'ai rencontré récemment
quelqu'un qui a été un haut dirigeant de
miss france je peux pas dire qui s'est
taillé la route des régions de miss
france
quelqu'un qui a été un routier les gens
de miss france mais il ya quand même des
hauts dirigeants niçois ben oui oui oui
voilà hudon la veille dans la ville et
quand je suis bien savourer travailler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec le gall arriver s'il arrêtait
s'user moi je suis aux dirigeants du
manuel mais croit on est en décembre de
l'année des trucs et la supercherie à
nos téléspectateurs donc qui m'a dit au
moment où il ya les 30 mise puis d'un
coup on envoie 12 mai ça dépend du vote
du jury qui a décidé un vote
discrétionnaire sans donner les
résultats
les ce vote là il est totalement
orientée par le poids des comités c'est
pas les plus belles mises c'est pas les
filles qui le mérite c'est le comité qui
ont le plus alors on a souvent parlé de
ce truc là quand ça passe de 30 à 12 c
myc donc si ça n'est pas le public qui
décide c'est vraiment passé le juré et
jury et cette personne là je vous laisse
après parlé m'a dit juste demandé je le
demande solennellement à au jury de de
légitimer de dire pourquoi ils ont
choisi ses miss quels sont les motifs
quels sont les critères
il ne le donnerons jamais pourquoi vous
croyez que le jury ad préférées oui
parce qu'il est où ils sont et sont
guidés par les rides et on leur dit
tiens le comité machin est très puissant
comité nord pas de calais celle là à les
sélectionner
je peux juste je peux juste répondre là
dessus il ya un voyage dans les îles de
une semaine avant l'élection miss france
et là on voit les filles de venir voir
ce qui se posent leur voix les fuit
comme à toulouse forte alors on voit les
pestes aussi donc celle là voilà en mai
il faut donc c'est intéressant que la
fille soit sympathique il faut qu'elle
soit sociale faut qu'elles soient polis
une qui voilà qui arrive pas à
s'intégrer ou qui est au lieu des louves
machin ben non mais bon voilà auquel
soit miss france après pour la suite
ensuite si on le laisse au test de
culture générale
non ici on est trop trop mauvaise note
elles pourront pas passer dans l'es12
parce que miss france elle doit
s'intéresser à tous et d'abord un peu de
culture générale
elle peut parler à n'importe qui donc
pendant ce voyage d'intégration comme on
voit les filles on voit qui elles sont
et on en choisit 12 potentiellement pour
devenir message alors attendez c'est
complètement fou ce que vous dites parce
que je suis vous nous suivez en direct
ce qui veut dire que quand vous arrivez
après votre voyage donc d'une semaine
quand vous arrivez vous savez déjà
quelles vont être les 12,9 qu'on va
garder nous on le sait pas les candidats
donc le long qu'un jury oui le savent
déjà et la production si oui si oui à
ces âmes une énorme escroquerie
et oui laurence et on sait qui est là où
la rizza non mais là ça sera très
attendu demain cela à faire les pitres
partout et non ses moi on est mort mais
deux manches et carlos et la journée
et si elle sera du jeu je vais expliquer
pour nos téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent c'est à dire qu'au départ il
ya combien de miss qui sont sélectionnés
qui m'ont sur le plateau direct 133
régis à berck comme vous faites un
voyage avant avec les 33 miss d'ailleurs
je me remet pourrait monter là dedans
donc là voilà vous êtes tranquilles en
vacances
et là on voit les pestes qu'un well it s
my au combat elle est retenue qu'elle
n'a pas voulu ouvrir une bombe dans la
piscine
on a des gars on voit ça c'est fait
voilà voilà une fois elle m'a volé ma
frite elle et eroglu à l'aquagym ya des
gars y voilà dans le dos le côté du son
en voiture de golf
tu veux boire deux minutes là braqués
suspecte à cannes de goal.com
voilà c'est vrai n'a pas voulu jouer au
golf elle dégage là pour vous le dis
donc c'est ça donc ce qui veut dire que
quand elle arrive en direct nous on
envoie 33 on est persuadé qu'elles sont
logés à la même enseigne est en fait la
production sait déjà qui oui vont être
les 12 finalistes
ça c'est oui c'est ouf fil info de ouf
gilles verdez encore une fois vous êtes
un enquêteur hors pair
[Applaudissements]
ces femmes à 41 et d'ailleurs je vous
transfert dès lundi sur maigret mais
c'était pas bonne parce que là on fait
un concours hug avec toute la france on
sait quand même que 12 d'ailleurs
incroyable ça qu'on avons interrompu
depuis mai mais l'a jamais été
voilà les gens sont au courant mais
blues c'est le jury et enfin si l'on
choisit
oui oui mais là ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que c'est un concours
de beauté mais on ne juge pas que sur le
physique il faut qu' elle soit 5,6 c'est
juste une belle d'anna et qu'elle est
antipathique c'est pas la peine parce
qu'elle doit devenir miss france donc
c'est celle qui est la plus représentée
la france les gens disent ok c'est quand
même fou c'est à dire que quand vous
regardez mes secondes c'est pas la peine
de regarder la première heure mais avec
voilà on allait fois la bulle dernière
vous appelé le halo être la sélection
des three lions vacances à hawaï a pris
un punch à pau mais surtout comment je
trouve ça hyper grave parce qu'on les
fait défiler pour rien bah oui pour une
école non mais c'est aussi les filles
qui sont pires que les gones à je te les
pauvres elles savent pas que c'est déjà
bien pour eux ces jeunes est déjà mort
elle défile pour rien très bonnes
interventions
o'kelly bas sur miss france je dis est
ce qu'on leur donne pas juste aux bonnes
chances supplémentaires de se rattraper
à ce moment-là ça c'est une question
mais c'est fini et en question pour toi
aussi est-ce que avant justement de
partir en voyage on vous dit qu'il ya
ces critères qui entrent en jeu
bien sûr on est on est tout au courant
les gens de questions pour lille gilles
c'est lui non ma vie j je vois esme ces
critères là j'en vois pas pourquoi ce
qu'effectivement le jury ne peut dire
officiellement qui est assez critique
qui choisissent non non non non non non
mais j p 500 de juger une personne sur
une semaine on voit on voit très
clairement comment l on voit si elle dit
bonjour on boit c'est lé symbole à
savoir vendre et c'est tout
donc tout le monde et au lej mm ans
avait passé un tour et donc voyez c'est
bon d'avoir une vraie info encore se
voir c'est à dire que les 33 miss arrive
mais elle défile y en a donc voila vous
faites le calcul
vingt-et-une ils vont défiler pour rien
puisque leur sort est déjà scellé leur
jeu patrick tu te font danser ouvre
quand même je sais pas maintenant le
savons maintenant
sitôt la première nommée sourire bonjour
bonjour mais que les membres du jury
soit avec vous en voyage
oui oui oui
alors merci je prends moi ça me sort
alain delon il ne voit on pas leurs noms
mais en fait tu joues à la patrie way
patrick jane j'allègerai jeunes obscures
donc non non non pas du tout ben arous
et un jury de présélection
mais quand on s'arrête mais brent à
patrick bruel repose la question on nous
pose des questions si ça reste pendant
les vacances mais ça veut dire tu es
tranquillement en train de prendre un
orangina schweppes la minute fois de ce
que tu peux me rappeler la date de
lead-in nord est et au match de tennis
ça dure combien une girafe
[Applaudissements]
l'aqua jeune homme du venezuela avec
tous ces mots ce que la mairie ne s'est
elle pas de déléguer sa mort
s'il vous plaît alors pourquoi est-ce
que le nord-pas-de-calais gagne toujours
pourquoi parce que tout simplement il ya
énormément de présélection par exemple
en alsace on a haut-rhin et bas-rhin
donc voilà dans le nord pas de calais ya
énormément d'élections et c'est que les
gagnantes qui - nord/pas-de-calais se
dire que c'est écrémé incroyablement est
super rebelle
ouais et pourquoi est ce qu'on regarde
maintenant nord pas de calais ce qui s'y
passe c'est parce que la curiosité est
attisée là dessus parce que ça fait
trois années de suite vous alsace 20
alsace elle a su passer outre tout ça
alors juste un an mais voilà juste prix
elle est fantastique sur la production
donc qui répète parce qu'il faut quand
même sa manche au sein des banques qui
produit les 33 aussi pour toutes les
dents jusqu'à la fin exactement et ça
c'est remarquable car bas tout comme ça
elle ça arrive
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sinon c'est sais même pas qui va sortir
on regarde pas là tant leur port étant
meurt pas de répéter tombeau les ondes
[Applaudissements]
le pire dans miss france parce que on
doit apprendre la position numéro une
si on et voilà en une de 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12
du reste si vous êtes appelés en deux
rencontres jusqu'à 12 ans 10e
vous avez parlé dans la même branche
voyez ce que je veux dire vous devez
apprendre la chorégraphie de ce côté
puis ensuite de ce côté mais elle était
confiante et donc tout dans l'espace
alors moi je vous dis on va beaucoup de
monde et je ne ferai jamais qu'on a
beaucoup demandé parce qu'on m'a élue
miss france plein de fois vous lis
jamais je le ferai vacciner mangerait
cette info mais mon nom je suis pas sûr
que tf1 mode et les séries on va voir on
avait posé une question sur twitter des
magouilles dans les secondes j'ai croisé
au moins 10% qui croient pas et là je
vous le dis les téléspectateurs doivent
être comme des oufs ça c'est une info
qui l'art est reprise partout donc vous
allez voir pau vingt-et-une fille voilà
qui vont penser qu'ils vont faire des
trucs pour rien voilà bah ça sera
l'élection de miss france fait bientôt
mais moi je regarde son tour jean pierre
foucault bien sûr je regarde pour
jean-pierre parce que je les aime et que
jean-pierre il peut faire n'importe
quelle émission de fermi se prendre
migdal faire miss patates il peut se
faire missing mr bergé
je le regarde je le kiffe maintenant
qu'on a vus mais on a balancé cette info
qui est qui est très bien il faudra
aussi changer ce règlement le règlement
est bizarre si tu as un petit tatouage
tu peux pas le faire si un mec
adaptation silencieux alors que le
comité de tonnerre les tatouages mai
vous avez pris de l'hélium dans la
fameuse rue du tout le goût mais ted
tolère les preuves de plus 3 cm bagarre
alors saluons vous pouvez faire ça aux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
visiteurs de sogen kato pour une
question et là j'ai des questions qui
tombe là les les français étaient les
spectateurs ils votent depuis le début
la raison les sauts il va nous péter vue
non ils votent les 12,6 et qu'il faut
continuer ou si un jour ils votent
depuis le début donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut voter pour des gens c'est donc ils
vont vérifier si ceci va voter madame
dhalla madame plusieurs effets
bienfaisants le nom en temps normal les
gens votent c'est une livre non ils
votent pour les douze rien du tout il
faut tu es vote et vote avant après
l'es12 je crois oui si c'est pas sûr que
si ces symboles sur mélenchon le jury
ses conceptions je ne sais pas si le
voisin il sait qui a voté enfin voila
c'est peut-être anonymes ou quoi qu'il
en soit encore d'ajouter un pavé mais
plus
mario les allées chéri en tout cas voilà
c'est une info exceptionnel qu'on vous a
donné ce soir